hey everybody michael knowles here host
of the eponymous
michael knowles show 2020
has been very confusing got a lot of
mixed messages this year
and somehow corporate america has made
it even more confusing
because they've been airing these woke
commercials
that are just selling leftist politics
you don't even know what product they
are selling
the actual physical product until the
very end when
maybe sometimes they tell you sometimes
they don't even do that a lot of you
have sent in some great woke commercials
for me to view and then try to guess
what product they're selling i don't
have a great
record on that i think i'm like three
for 14 or something
but nevertheless we keep trying i don't
think these companies are going to stop
moving into 21 it's 2021 rather
especially if they
continue along this political path where
you get joe
biden and you get all this all these
awful sorts of people
so make sure to keep sending those
commercials
in post in the comments section which
commercial you think
is the most woke commercial of the year
without further ado here are my absolute
favorites
from 2020.
the guy's a boss the woman is bossy
oh yeah poor women anyways because i
mean one of these
one of these feminism commercials okay
so he's persuasive
she's pushy yeah that said women have it
so hard in this country
that's why they live longer and make up
most college students right
because of how hard they have it you
know she's selfish
[Music]
neat and vain oh yeah yeah we never give
women credit for their physical beauty
no never not in this country
[Music]
it's a show-off yeah wow gosh it's hard
out there for uh for a lady today
i have no idea don't let labels hold you
back
i i have no idea what this is be strong
and shine
pantene proofy
not even a hint not everybody wakes up
happy
it's true sometimes you feel sad scared
crappy yeah oh this is gonna be a wrap
i can sense that why is that you let me
feel my way
[Music]
oh blue the woman's called a spanking
this is a pantene
can't wait to leave this closed-minded
town
[Music]
[Music]
this is like very generically liberal
i don't i don't know what it's not just
like only feminist or something
[Music]
it's like a moving company
i'm never moving out of my parents home
[Music]
just got ghosted i should have known
pretty sure i'm gonna say something like
a moving company because it's all about
moving and leaving
i'm too young to raise my baby girl take
your opinions
and suck it world
[Music]
it's actually kind of nice that she
raised the kid and didn't do abortion or
something like that
it's kind of it's pretty good they think
it's woke but it's not it's actually
pretty conservative
throwing his phone away i'm still going
to stick with like a moving
something
[Music]
a long commercial no one is happy all
the time
and that's okay stop it
stop
is that a burger king it's just burger
king
i guess a happy meal like a i guess
there's a tie in there
oh my gosh and then at the end burger
king supports the work of
mentalhealthamerica.net
that i you know i got to tell you
there's something very distasteful about
that i like the pun of it's a happy meal
and no one's happy all the time
but to exploit people who are going
through like clinical depression
and we're feeling suicidal to sell a
cheap hamburger they said i was too
pretty to fight
now she can't fight you're going to mess
up that beautiful face they said
i was too fat only skinny girls can
dress well
i don't speak that language tell me
about being a lawyer they said my nose
was too prominent they said i was too
masculine they thought the cat calling
was a compliment he said you can fix
those teeth quite easily boyish and ugly
when they were talking about female they
weren't talking about me this was not
pretty they would haul it from across
the street look sophisticated
embarrassing nose
chubby was too skinny manly crazy hate
never looked good while cute too
beautiful
too she said i said no way
you aren't me i'm me i'm not gonna be
defined by anyone's expectations i don't
dress my age
i dress myself the way i am because my
face has nothing to do with my boxing
i'm ranked number one in the country
number two in the world as a fashion
blogger
my style is 100 honorable passion like
nothing they've said has meant anything
it's like i'm not
you i'm me this is my hair my beauty my
beauty
my beauty my saying
[Music]
i have no idea i don't
[Music]
i i i don't i don't know i know they've
only said platitudes
my beauty my side
like what oh
man that's it's like there's this
there's this click hole advertising
campaign it was like you know one of
these satirical things it was like
are you going to take the pledge take
the pledge i take the pledge for my
community
i take the pledge for my faith i take
the pledge for me right and then you get
to the end and there's
they're not pledging anything that was
th this commercial
but unironically just like i'm me i'm
not you and i'm not him
i'm not my hair i'm not my kneecaps
i'm me and me is i and i
is the first person singular pronoun and
we
is the first person plural pronoun but i
am not we i am i
buy my shampoo there once was a man
who fell in love with his own reflection
all day he stood into a pool
starving others of his attention
as the weeks moved he was glued
some thought he'd eat himself like food
so this is selling like barack obama's
next book or something it seems like a
pretty app description
until self-worship
turned him into a gift
a gift not just for him to treasure
[Music]
but a gift that brought the whole world
pleasure
and so i put this question to you all
does that not make self-obsession
the most selfless act of all do you love
me
[Music]
what
this is so creepy make yourself a gift
to the world
do you love me
[Music]
equinox gym that was a gym
you know what's so amazing about that as
i thought there was going to be this
really profound point
about you know narcissism and or
self-obsession as a culture why that's
bad you know i thought they'd kind of
cast right-wingers or something as
self-obsessed even though
it would seem that the left checks that
box a little more these days
but then it became an out and out
defense
of narcissism
this is not new
this has happened before
in every downturn and disaster in
history
gender equality has been set back as
women
have stepped forward oh i thought this
is not new with the masks but now it's a
feminist
heavy cost more of the frontline care
more of the pay cuts more of the jobs
lost
more of the responsibilities at home
keeping them from going back to paid
work
these times are not unprecedented
but they give us another chance for
equality if we all choose to step
forward as equals
i have no idea equal higher so again
[Music]
ah procter gam wait procter gamble
gillette also i guess like all those
companies
you know it was a total hail mary when i
said credit card because it just had the
font that you see in credit card
commercials
who said that the lady at the store
that is not a compliment it's an ugly
nasty word
and you are going to hear it nothing i
can do about that
but you are not going to let that word
hurt you was it like the n word i guess
yeah that's what happens all the time
right white people just always calling
black guys the n word all the time
yeah the only time you actually hear the
n word by the way is in rap music but a
good driver yeah that's it over
horrible racism getting a ticket this is
about you not coming home
oh yeah racist cops just uh slaughter
innocent black people all over the
country you know that
of course that's what always happens
i mean statistically it doesn't happen
like a dozen times
you are beautiful unarmed and unknown by
the way it doesn't mean not justified
but
point for another time i'll never forget
that let's talk about the talk
racist cops uh uh
to procter and gamble again ah i should
have guessed that
hey hey you okay
i'm good
[Music]
it could be a car commercial
well they lesbian i think they're
lesbians right of course
[Music]
it could be like a home insurance
commercial
look at you hi baby
mom this is amy oh hi amy
hey dad hey i'm amy
hi nice to meet you are you hungry oh
that white guy doesn't like the lesbian
thing homemade
darn white guys
oh dad's happy to see the straight kids
he just doesn't like the lesbians
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
white neighbor lady doesn't like it
[Music]
a white guy really hates the lesbian
thing
happy birthday hey dad
hey night night
good night
it's kind of like over the top even if
there was a straight couple like you're
unmarried you're like lying around
kissing each other in your parents house
it's not it's not like really acceptable
[Music]
sharing a bed yeah unmarried you can't
no wonder the dad's upset
what is he doing
dad
it's like a movie i have no idea what
it's like there isn't a product
did i do it right oh
do you like it a loving world starts
with a loving it's a home insurance
[Music]
show you're a proud parent
[Music]
uh
this would be the usual one is like the
candy's poisoned so check your candy
maybe it's that it's probably that
oh it's not candy that's a pumpkin there
we go
all right first one changes an extra
piece of candy uh
i think i see where this is going
it's like you can't do the different
races of superheroes is that right
[Music]
thank you for keeping our streets safe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay it probably is the candy thing
again right
like the people are poisoning the candy
[Applause]
oh no are you freaking kidding me
they're going to trans the kids they're
going to make us trans the freaking kids
it's so creepy i can't i don't even i
don't even i don't have no i have no
further comment
this is creepy and and whatever that is
we society should do the opposite
you